you're sexist yeah probably next okay a
19 year old is more attractive than a 26
year old woman she's fresh and i can
[ __ ] put my imprint on her but at
some point hate that gets creepy because
you're 35. i'm gonna get canceled for
this
all right so we took a quick
intermission between the first part of
this tate and the famous nut boys video
we can just get right back into it sure
um but before we go any further i am
giving away 100 to someone who likes
subscribes and joins the discord in my
comments and also 99 of you guys are not
subscribed so hit the [ __ ] button
please please all right men try and find
hot chicks and show them the world yeah
so you have to be there first right it's
not easy to do i'm not saying that it's
easy i'm saying you get there first
though it's how'd you get the first pg
about it
there are the odd ones you can't find
the old one who's a bit older who hasn't
had too much experience in life or sat
around some dork for a while or whatever
but in general this is also one of the
reasons men find youth attractive you
want to blow up the internet i'll pull
up the internet right [ __ ] now the
reason 18 and 19 year olds are more
attractive than 25 year olds because
they've been through less dig i'll say
this right here on the [ __ ] internet
i don't give a [ __ ] people sit there and
go you can't say that yes i can a 19
year old is more attractive than a 26
year old woman i'll tell you why because
that 26 year old has talked to more guys
been to the club more times been more
places
it
it just depends on the girl i mean he's
hanging out in he's hanging out in clubs
and all these fancy places where all
these women go to hang out to meet men
and and show off this guy's not hanging
out in the bible belt
he's not going to church to find pretty
young girls yeah he's not like going
after the farmer's daughter i was
talking about that with my friends last
night though i kind of i do think that's
true and that's like a big reason as to
why younger women are more attractive
and it's also because that they're in
like the prime age of their lives when
you're in like 18 to 22 that's like the
best you're gonna look most likely i
don't know have you not wait till you
get 30 like 30 but it's not like the
prime time women women not only are
still gorgeous they don't get old
looking yet unless they really like you
know drank themselves to death or
whatever but they also they have a
confidence about them at that age and
there's i think that that's like the
sweet spot for women where they're the
most gorgeous hmm which i'm just saying
from a biological standpoint i'm glad
you're not attracted to 35 year old
women right now but when you're there we
can we can revisit this comment in
amsterdam i was attracted to a 30 year
old like the one in the window no
did you go with the
yeah we looked in the windows oh we
didn't talk about that when you tell
them you got to tell me about that it
was funny they're uh they're like wink
at you and they're like coming here and
i'm like oh you didn't go did you god no
okay
we were sitting at a bar across the
street from like one one of the red
light doors and this one girl went
through six guys in like 45 minutes i
swear to god we were counting as guys
would go in it was incredible it was
incredible to see all right i'm glad you
don't need antibiotics now there's more
arguments more heartbreak more [ __ ]
more mess for me to clean up where's the
19 year old i agree i know that is so
true they've been through more that's
like the biggest point is that the more
they sleep with the more guys they get
heartbroken by the more [ __ ] that they
end up dealing with and it is just more
of a mess for you to clean up rather
than someone who's more of a clean slate
and you can just put a good impression
on them and they're not heartbroken from
past relationships and they're more
ready to just have a healthy
relationship with you
absolutely right no i do agree that you
can that a clean slate is better than
dealing with someone's emotional baggage
unless they're good at dealing with
their own emotional baggage and they
don't bring it to every relationship and
everything they do every day which is
something that older women get better at
young girls man yeah they hold on it was
hurt before any girl with like a
previous toxic ex that's such such a red
flag if she had like a boyfriend that
she knew was toxic and she stayed with
him and then she went back to him get
get the [ __ ] out of there yeah there's
she's always talking about her exes yeah
same with a guy if the guy's always
talking about his exes i'm like what are
we doing here talking about your ex get
the [ __ ] out like if we're having one
conversation once about our past
relationships just to like you know get
to know each other better you know on a
date six that's fine but yeah but oh my
god if that's all you talk about if all
you're talking about is gina go call
gina get the hell out of here just broke
up she's fresh and i can [ __ ] put my
imprint on her make her a good person
and without her having to go through all
that detriment to learn about life yes
but at some point hate that gets creepy
because you're 35. wait wait you're
telling me you were innocent and sweet
for this dude you were nice to him he
[ __ ] you and messed you up and now i
deal with the attitude problem you've
developed because he got your [ __ ] i
didn't even want him to [ __ ] you in the
first place you should have been a
virgin when you met me no i'm pregnant
with your [ __ ]
get [ __ ] goodbye don't you think
though the language tape
potty mouth trying to find purity out of
women it kind of is like a low
possibility i mean it's kind of like
when a woman says i want a guy that's
like six feet tall whatever the case may
be right there's less of them and like
it's like dude you can't really find
them
the best things in the world are low
probability it doesn't mean it's not
what we desire we're talking about we
what we desire and what i'm saying is
that one of the best things about status
is that you can now get what you desire
so at status most men have this dream of
sleep with endless swim this is what a
lot of people don't realize is that he's
talking about like a pretty like not the
majority of men he's the top point one
percent of men so he can get the top
point one percent of women and if what
he says and his standards are crazy to
the 99 of people it's not crazy to him
it's what he wants and is what he gets
that makes perfect sense if that's what
he like demands that's he gets what he
thinks is the top point one percent of
women in his mind in his opinion i could
if i decided could sleep with a new
woman every single day for the next 10
years all i would have to do is reply to
my instagram inbox it would not be
difficult i could do it it's not
interesting to me i am more interested
in using my status to find something
extremely rare like a woman of innocence
that's what i'm talking about here i'd
rather find one two three four maybe
five women of innocence and keep them as
opposed to just sleeping with endless
women because sex really ain't all that
interesting to me i think it gets boring
after a while
so
that's the point we're making yes facts
aren't defined but just because it's
hard to find doesn't mean it's not what
every man intrinsically really wants
that's what men really truly want and
what's actually interesting about it all
is no matter how
innocent the female
she still wants the man to have had
experience
if you were to ask a virgin woman do you
want a virgin boyfriend she'd say no
or if she'd stuck with one man and she'd
lived a good life do you want a man to
lift a good life and being with one
woman
no maybe it's you just slept with a few
more they want you to have been xyz
right so you can you could have been a
playboy and stuff with a thousand girls
and get with a virgin she wants you to
be that way and you want her to be that
way it's fine that's how it's supposed
to work i didn't know about that like
she wants you to be that way because i
know a lot of girl like i i haven't seen
that personally i don't i think a lot of
a lot of younger women especially are
insecure even older like it's just a
bulk of women that are insecure and they
when they know that a man's been with a
lot of other women all they do in their
mind is compare themselves to these
other imaginary women and it drives them
insane so he's and it makes them jealous
and more insecure
and so
he doesn't understand what goes on in a
lot of women's minds he's dead wrong
about this but women out here some of
the hundred dudes sleeping with a guy
who [ __ ] like 15 chicks and he wonders
why you can't keep her under control of
course [ __ ] not i'm gonna pull that
off it's hard for guys it's hard for
dudes man because these chicks are just
running through dick it's hard and if
they run through enough dick they're
eventually gonna end up on some [ __ ] a
real a real jeez dick
we talk about i get called a lot on the
internet one of these red pill guys and
it annoys me because i mean oh this
whole red pill man's madness fear what
does red pill mean oh sorry about girls
and dating and all this [ __ ] i'm not one
of them but sir a lot some of the things
they say is true and the point i'm
trying to make is that if if you get
with a woman who slept with enough dudes
eventually some of those dudes are gonna
leave an imprint on her you can't fill
any i i'll be honest with you i feel
sorry for any man who's with any of my
exes
you're gonna come along
you ain't me
i could whoop your ass she knows i can
whip your ass
you can't give her what i give her you
can't do what i can do and now you're
sitting there going oh i still love you
and and the deepest darkest night she's
laying there next to you going you ain't
andrew
you just tried your very best you just
tried your very best and that didn't
feel like it when tate did it i'm not
responding because
it's you guys it's true that's i we
talked about this in the last video how
i like i don't know why it is but you
like it when your ex goes to the next
person and they're like uglier or like
lower than you you're like
no and i did say i don't compare myself
to other maybe it's a guy's thing i
don't compare myself to other women but
i do
compare men to each other yeah of course
if i run through 10 chicks i get to know
i've ruined 10 wives guaranteed 10
divorces guaranteed because whoever she
marries she will not be happy with it
she will dream of me for the rest of her
[ __ ] human existence guaranteed
that's how it gets you get to that point
at a certain status of man how do you
get to that point
you gotta get your [ __ ] together
what push-ups you've done today
on the [ __ ] day why don't you ask me
something questions how many have you
done bro i can put i'm ready i live
ready i do push-ups in my sleep how many
push-ups do you do today
i don't really train the gym too often i
do like 500 1000 push-ups a day whenever
whenever i'm if i'm ever on the computer
i set myself on target so if i'm on the
computer and i'll i'll set a time or
i'll say when this song ends or whatever
mentally and then i'll just drop into as
many as i can you try to do it 500 to
100
i live on the road so i don't often get
access to a gym you guys don't just go
to the gym i'm like well if i stay in a
nice hotel there'll be gyms but i do
lots of like car rallies and [ __ ] i'm on
the car i'm about to go to a boat for a
week and this kind of shit's hard right
but you can you can easily diet really
good then no
not really you eat whatever the [ __ ] you
want
to drink a lot of smoke he makes no
excuses and i like that but he's not he
he's on a boat he's doing he's on a bus
he's on a car like he makes time to
exercise you can just drop and do a
hundred push-ups that's all you gotta do
it's all you gotta do and people like oh
i can't you know people are always like
i don't have the time i don't have the
you know i don't belong to the gym or
the gym's too far away or all kinds of
lame excuses do some [ __ ] push-ups
hit the deck and do some push-ups and
you that's all you need anyway a lot of
the time i'm in the gym i'm doing
push-ups pretty much between every
workout it's like 10 to 15 push-ups
that's good there's another thing that
actually ties into things we're talking
about where it's actually detrimental
when women and men live together
completely and exclusively women always
say this when women get real g they try
to attach themselves to you don't live
with your boys anymore good that uh live
with just me come on we'll be a real
couple blah blah and i understand why
they want that because they want to
remove you from all the [ __ ] they're
afraid of right the girls to parties to
fun they want you to completely rely on
them so they have power and control over
you but if you live exclusively just
with a chick you are not going to be as
competitive as a man so it's not smart
it's not well it's going to make her
happy that's fine but i'm talking about
purely emotion out of it logically
you're not going to be as competitive as
a man as if you live with your boys who
are competitive 100 000 yeah well you
shouldn't go living with a girl anyway
unless you're unless you're honestly
i would say to that we should make a a
switch back to old-fashioned values that
you move in together when you get
married because people move in they move
out they move in they move out and then
everything it's kind of like how he
talks about how women when they have a
lot of sex they just it it means less
and less every time and when you just
move in with somebody you know you can
just easily move out and it takes away
the commitment so he's right stay with
your boys and i think you should stay
with your boys and stay in your own life
until you're ready to really find the
right girl and jump in the deep end on
that yeah as a guy in our in like our
teenage and twenties we cannot be
stressing about girls and that and make
that our priority you need to surround
yourself with other people who want the
same goals that you're going for
they're they're hard working they're
trying to make money and you gotta like
surround yourself with them all the time
personally for me i surrounded myself
with those people online but i was on
calls with them all day working finding
new strategies that's what i was doing
for 12 hours a day yeah not saying that
relationships aren't fulfilling and
important but to make i know a lot of
people men and women that make their
whole life about i'll be happy when i
find that when i find true love and just
be happy now period just be happy go out
live your life spend time with your your
guys your girls the people that make you
better you know and instead of sitting
there pining every night wishing you had
somebody that's so lame it's really
terrible no that's trash
it's a waste everyone knows this you
can't go looking for a girlfriend you
need to build yourself up to a high
enough status of a man till the girls
just come to you that's no that's that's
honestly just the truth though you can't
go around looking for girls and being a
little bit making women your priorities
and that gives them the advantage over
you you live with five millionaires and
they're telling you every day how much
money they're making you're gonna be
really pissed off being broke you're
gonna be furious yeah yeah you ain't
gonna have it 100 you're living with
your chick and you're broke but you know
she cooks for you
she sucks dick good you watch netflix
you can get very very comfortable very
very quickly with very very little
living with the chick
so there's another reason another thing
is the reason like intrinsically men do
a lot of the stuff they do like they
work hard go to the gym is to get girls
so if you're settling down with the girl
already just living with her doing all
the [ __ ] that he just said like very
complicitly then you lose that hunger
for wanting to build and become a better
person so that you can earn what you
really want which is like women we're
talking about status and how women love
status but are you gonna be a high
status man if you're not competitive no
so you'll get a chick you'll fall in
love with her you go this is a really
good one let me move in with her let me
do the right thing
you're gonna live with her and you're
slowly over a matter of time years
months whatever gonna fall off
and now there's other dudes out there
who are hungry
bro and then you're gonna wonder why you
get why everyone's getting divorced i'll
tell you why because you moved in with
that [ __ ] you've got a belly sitting
around eating lasagna that's why i will
say that's true i mean like i had a
girlfriend once and i felt like i wasn't
doing as much but once it was over it
was game over i was going you get what
you put your energy into so if you're if
you're in a relationship and it's
consuming and you're you can't put all
your energy into your career or whatever
it is you're trying to do you can't put
all your energy into the relationship so
everything ends up half-assed
once you really get to a certain level
of success though when you really have
things smoothed out then
to get a partner to share that with is a
whole other story yeah you got to dial
in you got to get your [ __ ] together
yeah and you got to be with somebody
that's not going to be like you're
working again oh i'm jealous come pay
attention to me yeah you know no screw
that a good woman will do what she's
supposed to do which is make your life
comfortable right she'll cook for you
chill
blah blah blah which is fine that's what
she's supposed to do she's a good chick
but it's going to make you comfortable
it's going to make you lazy you are
going to lose your competitive edge
not everybody wants to be super
competitive like some people are content
and he and even you made a comment in
one of the videos that like you know if
you're working at 95 that sucks it
doesn't suck for everybody it sucks for
a lot of people who had other dreams and
other things and not everybody wants to
be tate you know if there's like a
chubby guy at home with his wife he may
just really be the happiest guy on earth
his life is simple he has what he wants
he he's looking mom someone's got to
cook the fries someone has to live those
mundane lives i'm speaking to the people
that want to have the freedom to do
whatever they want if you're working
that nine to five what you get 10
vacation days the whole year if you want
to travel you have to take off you need
to save up money like that is not what i
want at all right that's not free i want
freedom of my time the enough money to
do whatever i want if i want to go to
europe next week i can do it yeah i want
all that too and i'm just saying that
but that's like but that's what i'm just
saying that you have to really it's hard
to put yourself in the mindset of
somebody else who just doesn't give a
[ __ ] about that doesn't care totally
content and that those people are
actually probably happier because
they're just content life is good well
yeah the what what is it ignorance is
bliss just make them ignore it no i know
i'm not saying it makes you ignorant but
if you're just content and you're stupid
and you think nothing's going on you're
nice and happy you know you are saying
they're ignorant and you just use the
word ignorant and stupid i'm just saying
npcs i don't know what i'm saying what's
the best word for you and i want one
thing right we want the same things we
want freedom we want financial freedom
freedom with our time you know ability
to do whatever we want i want land and
dogs you want whatever you want all i'm
saying is london dogs
don't [ __ ] on other people because
they are they want something else some
people actually want something else then
there are i don't think that they
naturally want to know but then there's
no there's there
is a group of people that do want that
and then there's people who are in that
same lifestyle as them but aren't happy
with it like we're saying like those
people are miserable they wake up every
day they hate their jobs they look over
their spouse and they're like oh and
then they you know they they're not
happy with their house they're not happy
with their bank account but they don't
have the guts to do anything about it
that's the people that i can see what
you're talking about but i just need you
to understand that there are good
perspectives that you haven't considered
yeah no i get it some oh
oh i'm joking
some people are genuinely just content
and they're fine with working that nine
to five but i know i'm a not a majority
but a lot of those people too are upset
with working that nine to five yes and
they wish that they had that other
lifestyle yes because i get hundreds of
dms a day of people asking me to help
them with like my like my previous
business adventures and all that stuff
so that's pr maybe i'm a little bit
biased because i get tons of dms and
[ __ ] like that so who knows i just don't
see why people would be content even
like my family and stuff that i talked
to that works nine to five jobs
they're content with it but then you
travel and you're like damn i wish i
could do this all the time so yeah no
[ __ ] wouldn't anybody you get it women
are just women or women are required to
a certain degree to soften men i
understand that and having no women in
your life at all will make you dangerous
it'll take it too far but you can't go
too far the other way and just become
[ __ ] soft yeah what's your thought on
islam and everything because i know in
the quran and stuff like you could have
up to four wives and stuff so
i've seen you talk about it a little bit
but i would like to know like
i think it's the last religion on the
planet
that's the right religion i think it's
the last religion so if it's the last
true religion on the planet then it has
to be the correct one because i don't
think how is it the last one it's the
last reason because no other religion
has boundaries which they enforce
if you stand if you will tolerate
everything then you stand for nothing if
your book says x
but you refuse to say the book says this
i'm sick
that's not true he says he reads the
bible the bible has parameters and
boundaries yeah but a lot of christians
don't actually follow like the real
rules of the bible sure there are some
smooshy muslims too that follow you know
the more we're different we we just take
spirituality differently like not as
much as like super jesus and all that
stuff i'm more of an energy kind of
person so if you put out good positive
energy you do good things to others i
see that will come back to you but i
don't look at like one specific god or
like specific rules in a bible that i
have to follow i kind of just try to be
a good person do good and that'll come
back around yeah that's christianity if
you're a christian
99 percent of christians are ignoring
every single rule inside the bible okay
everybody should interpret the bible
you're saying like they like pick and
choose what they want to oh yeah they
try and say i interpret it differently i
believe in god but you know i don't
believe in that part that that's not
what the book says it doesn't seem to be
that's so funny because when i was in
amsterdam it was pride week there and
they have gay flags all over the
christian church yeah yeah we support
the gays
sorta i got into it with a guy in church
uh last uh last week because he was
very adamant that the bible says being
gay is a sin and i said i i just think
that jesus is all loving and all
forgiving and god is supposed to be a
father and everybody's there his
children and it's fine i go and if
people are being moral and you know
loyal to each other and not not breaking
any of the commandments and
you know not cheating and coveting other
people's spouses or whatever then
they're good people and he was just
pissed yeah he was very adamant and so
tate is right that we interpret things
but any biblical or quran or torah
scholar any of those three books there
are people that have been debating about
that for centuries about tiny little
words and what they mean so tate coming
in and making this blanket statement is
just shows his ignorance frankly on the
topic only muslims follow their book no
true no true so somebody's saying all
muslims are perfect muslims okay
okay whatevs i don't care he's i don't
know personally my like i just don't
care enough about people's affairs to
like get worked up or anything about it
like if you're gay i don't give a
solitary [ __ ] but that's not what we're
talking about yes i know yeah i sounded
like i sounded like so much right now no
i love people no matter what but this
isn't what the conversation is but i'm
just saying like when i hear people like
like i don't know going so deep into
other people's affairs like that like i
guess we're talking about it so maybe
i'm being a hypocrite but i don't know
like in real life like i really just
don't give a [ __ ] like if you're gay
like i think it's weird like with like
transgender stuff like i i don't care
what you want to do but like when you're
they just go too far like with like
women playing i mean men playing in
women's sports like they always got to
make the [ __ ] they've got to take it too
far and ruin it piss everybody off when
everybody was just whatever at first it
was like yeah i guess you can be gay who
cares and then it's like well now i'm a
i'm a man it's like okay you're a man i
want i want to play woman sports why do
you got to go so far with everything i'm
sure there's i'm sure there's a lot of
muslims who don't completely follow the
quran but i'm saying that if you were to
go out there and try and find muslims
who live true to the quran completely
you can find them yeah you ain't going
to find it you can find christians
yeah
he's dead right again
he's living i don't know he's living
i can speak for american christians and
there are so many different levels of us
and so many different kinds of us but
some people are living to the literal
interpretation of the bible as they
interpret it and those people are seen
as like weirdos to be honest in america
they're like oh my you won't sleep with
anyone until you're married like they're
looking perceived as weird people in the
states maybe maybe you don't think maybe
in pop culture but not in their own
worlds he's he's being on campus here
and like muslim [ __ ] like that's right
like a woman
bro you should put me in any [ __ ]
church give me the hottest church
there's muslim [ __ ] out there i'm sure
there are but i'm saying he's the point
he's making is you can find a bunch of
women who adhere to islam who are still
virgins at the age of 25 waiting for an
embraced marriage oh yeah you will not
find that under christianity
yeah you could find a couple but you're
right there's probably more muslims i'm
gonna get canceled for this but i know
that the majority of church girls i know
at college and stuff are the biggest
hoes really the ones with the bible
quotes in their bio
streets yeah you know i can i've known
guys who are putting up bible quotes on
facebook and talking about their church
and i know for a fact that they cheat on
their wives and their jerks so so yeah
girls who love frat guys [ __ ] girls who
love frat guys there's hypocrites
everywhere it's it's crazy but him
saying that it's only christianity uh is
is obnoxious and he's also lumping all
christians into one thing when it the
christianity spectrum is very wide girls
who love frat guys and the bible quotes
in the instagram biographies a lot man
you hate those mofos huh i don't hate
the frat guys i hate the girls that love
frat guys okay okay the difference
they're evil no i agree i hate sorority
girls
with islam you can't get away with it
even if you're saying that there's some
islam [ __ ] etcetera etcetera fine
that's cool
but people don't stand up and openly
disrespect islam oh hell no because
they're afraid
so once again if you don't have rule
systems and doctrines and beliefs and
prophets which people are afraid to mock
are you even a religion
people won't disrespect islam nobody
will disrespect it because they're
scared
even in a christian country what do you
want to do what do you mean by
disrespect i mean disrespect it say
something disrespect it i you can walk
around if you could wear a t-shirt
saying jesus is gay
right here in croatia christian country
and you will make it out of the country
alive i dare you to do the same thing
with the islamic prophet yeah dare you
to do the same thing yeah because if you
draw a picture of the prophet you can
get your head chopped off because the
extreme the extremists in in
christianity suck but the extremists in
the muslim community yeah they won't
they'll cut your head off or draw on a
picture of their prophet it's it's
ridiculous so yes he's right it's not
worth it they'll blow up a building yeah
no really look what they did to that
newspaper what were they just in that
newspaper i'm joking let's keep going
it's not too far it's [ __ ] truth even
in christian countries you are not safe
to do that you do not disrespect their
beliefs yeah disrespecting our lives no
you don't do that yeah you don't nobody
doesn't so what i'm saying
if they're the last religion on earth
that people are afraid to disrespect if
their god is the last god on earth that
people are afraid to disrespect then
he's the only god that matters for now
for now what this guy what this guy
isn't catching is that you know
christians came to america hundreds of
years ago really you know i grew up in
new york and so yeah we had we had
muslims you know always but
the muslim community has really just
started coming in droves the middle
eastern community has just started
coming in droves here in the last 20 30
years or so so they're they still have a
generation or two to become americanized
so their religion is going to get
watered down just like christianity and
there's going to be different levels of
muslims because they're going to marry
like it or not muslims you're going to
marry some american girls you're gonna
have a son or a daughter that marries an
asian or a black guy or a white girl or
an irish girl and that's what's gonna
happen so he's he's he's on to something
for now but he's not looking forward and
seeing how it how it's gonna change so
you don't think they'll stay strict to
the real rules of the religion they're
gonna try just like just like everybody
did when they got here my grandfather
hated uh grandma my mother because she
was half irish hated her he was italian
he was from sicily he hated other
italians from other parts of italy he
hated everybody like he was he was so he
was a wonderful grandparents park bought
me ice cream played cards with me he
played tic-tac-toe but he was such a
racist everybody's every time he hated
everybody right and but he hated grandma
because she was half irish it's not even
that big of a leap and so you go but
that's but that was uh generationally i
have other stories in the family of the
same thing italians who hated the irish
that were brought home you know as a as
a suitor or a potential wife
so it but after a generation it's cool
everybody we all love each other look
we're all italian and irish now it's
like italian irish people are the same
[ __ ] oh you're tying irish a big deal
yeah a lot of us are mixed now and so it
it just is going to take a generation so
yeah they're going to change it's going
to happen she's calling it now all these
old serious people are going to are
going to die off like my my my sweet
grandpa he he was rough he had a hitler
mustache when i was a little kid
like
decades after hitler was um
was killed yeah he was crazy he was
something else but again ice cream park
took me for rides in the car he was
awesome as a grandpa but what a great
grandpa wow playing video games and
[ __ ] shot at stupid [ __ ] dressed up
gay on tv shows
what kind of [ __ ] what kind of
religion is that
it's a joke yo
it's a good point man how come you're
the like do you ever get afraid of
getting cancelled for being so you said
the [ __ ] you say did you just say
firstly are you afraid of being canceled
and i i don't know i understand
i mean that in the sense where it's like
you seem to say crazy [ __ ] and your
audience gets bigger when usually people
who say some [ __ ] that you say
a lot of people would come after them
that's true but first i don't live in
fear so i'm not afraid of anything but
how could you get canceled because most
of your [ __ ] is not even your own
accounts right secondly
i'm just breaking down the sentence as a
professional because that's what i do
you said fear of getting canceled the
first word incorrect was fear i'm not
afraid of anything i don't live in fear
second thing is canceled if i was gonna
be afraid of anything on the planet the
last thing i'd be afraid of is getting
canceled like i've had people try to
kill me i have real enemies as we stand
right now there are groups of men waking
up who want bullet in my head
i'm not i don't give a [ __ ] if some dork
on the internet makes a video saying
cancel tape don't give a solitary [ __ ]
see me and tater
i don't give a [ __ ] who cancels me who
tries to cancel me i'm done i i noticed
i have feelings about how people thought
about me but it's been decades since
i've given a [ __ ] the amount of hate
comments that i get i literally i'm numb
do it at this point i don't give a [ __ ]
i know i've been getting hate comments
too since we started this yeah but you
get a lot of proof your mom is is pretty
comments you get a little i get a lot of
balance i'm not here for the [ __ ] kid
i'm here for your mom
like it's
it's like three weeks on youtube man
relax a bunch of kids we're a team kid
it is what it is
like ernie
bert i wish you wouldn't drink so much
bert well ernie i wish you wouldn't eat
cookies in the damn bed bert you're
shouting again bert i don't know why i
said barney i did the 10k post on
instagram and they're like you're not
even gonna thank your mom like bro i
live with her g i thank her i talked to
her in person i don't get a post on
youtube community that i love my mother
like what also just want to get a quick
heads up to you tate accounts whenever
you guys repost our videos they print
like three three four million views go
repost that [ __ ] on tick tock come on
what are you doing that's crazy i know
you're you're pretty tick tock famous
you're over over 10 million views you
that's hilarious
let's keep going most people
intrinsically even have a it's a lesser
version of even if it's less extreme
agree with me most men intrinsically
agree with a lot of the things i say
i'm surprised no feminists have ever
come out like come for your neck no no
they've tried but how can you come from
my neck how can you come from my neck
when their their basic battle cry and
their basic weapons are ineffective you
know what i was thinking about too is
that he's like almost a threat to like
the us government because he's saying
stuff that they don't want to be spread
and i was thinking like what if they
just like took him out but he's escaped
himself from the matrix so much that it
would be like kind of a mission for the
us government to even go and take him
out because he literally lives at like
the top of a mountain in romania with
armed guards like he is literally a
super villain it's pretty crazy uh okay
maybe i'm missing something but what is
it that he has done that the us
government would want to take him out
for like exposing the true the real
truth of the indoctrination of people
and how we are pretty much born to be
made into slaves to the system i mean he
talks about it a lot more in the podcast
spoiled earlier i had to watch the thing
before i reacted to it with my mom okay
so okay we'll get to it because i
haven't seen him see
and he gets like it gets nuts at like
the hour 30 mark so we'll see i mean
there are a lot of people online that
are doing that that are fighting there's
a lot of people like that but i would
genuinely be scared if i was speaking
that truth like exposing the government
for stuff in the usa i would kind of be
scared they'll look what they do to
donald trump i mean they just they just
raided the president how many people
have suspiciously died yeah oh no the
corruption on all sides and uh in all
politics in all countries on all sides
is corrupt as hell so guys yeah i am not
suicidal so if i die it was not me me
too but i'm not saying anything that
creates no one no one's coming for us
i'm paranoid let's keep going i'm a
misogynist okay next you're sexist yeah
probably next
okay i'm going to cancel you don't give
a [ __ ] i ain't got enough to cancel i
want everyone else's account i ain't got
an account next okay well well we can't
call him an in-cell uh
you're a misogynist like it's just a
circle they don't have any weapons
yeah how are you gonna sit there to the
dude with a bunch of beautiful
relationships with somebody where you
were talking about just a political
policy maybe and if you didn't agree
with them they would go well you're
racist oh that was the worst like being
called a racist for years for having a
different opinion was just after at
first i was hurt i was like what do you
mean i'm a racist i'm not a racist
and then now i'm like and then after a
while i was like okay fine you think i'm
fine i'm a racist but you still can't
address the problems that you're arguing
about if you call someone if you call
someone a name like racist like how do
you come back from it you have to say
well i'm not racist because and then
what they do is they dismantle all of
those points you're like yeah i have
black friends that i hang out with all
the time i'm not racist my brother my
legit my step brothers by saying that
just because your brother's black
doesn't mean you're not racist you can
still hate black people i'm like shut up
dude just because i think that black
lives matter is a scam and they've
stolen tens of millions of dollars from
people doesn't mean that i don't like
black people it is [ __ ] dumb they
were literally the biggest rug pull of
the market try to do research on what
blm has how blm has the organization has
improved guess what it's gone now that
the election's over oh my god it was
just disappeared one month disappeared
and black lives didn't matter anymore
look try to do research on what that
organization has done to improve black
communities good luck and then let me
know what you're finding in the last
video
these chicks are hot and they chose me i
don't even [ __ ] what you say
i'm not interested it's actually very
unfortunate it's kind of unfortunate
because women are completely and utterly
solely judged on how they look
like a lot of these feminists are
[ __ ] they're so busted
like you if you're gonna be a fellow at
least get hot
oh the hot [ __ ]
if you're hot you matter you matter more
like than the views of guys that is mom
um don't even act like this is not the
truth because like look at i got that
you you're good looking do you think
that this would be doing as well if you
weren't as good looking if you were an
ugly busted mom that was fat do you
think that that you this like people
would would care about your opinion as
much i would think that i would have to
have an even better personality
you know what me and my friends say when
we like show each other a girl we're
talking to or something and she's
stationed she's ugly we're like oh yeah
no she looks nice she looks real nice
these feminists are [ __ ] they're so
busted
like you if you're gonna be a feminist
at least get hot first because if you're
hot you'll matter oh the hot [ __ ] said
this i'm so scared
you said this oh you hear what i'll be
[ __ ] said have you ever heard no one
cares nobody cares you're ugly it's just
nobody cares i understand what you're
doing he's being really mean about it
he's being really big but he's
he's not wrong and i'm not saying that
that's how i feel but society he's right
and that's why the feminists in part are
pissed off because they're saying that
women are objectified and it's all about
how they look but then some of those
very same women go out and like do nude
scenes in in
in tv and
spend all kinds of time just
objectifying themselves and putting
their boobies on only fans because while
they're saying that they're feminists
it's free the nipple he's not wrong
facts no no put your nipples on me and
the hot [ __ ] with me i get it you're
mad at god that's fine but but what do
you do cancel me i don't care make a
video keep making videos i don't care
there's a direct correlation between
that right hot girls aren't gonna come
after you but the ugly ones will well
hot girls hot girls love
men
who are prepared to protect provide take
care of them if you're prepared to
protect provide and take care to a
degree you see yourself in a position of
authority to a degree right it's my i
need to take care of her i'm gonna pay
her rent she's gonna come on my boat
she's gonna listen to me she's gonna
have a good life you see yourself
in a position of authorities which means
to some degree you are misogynistic
women beautiful women love misogynistic
men when you see a 19 year old ukrainian
on a billionaire's yaw in dubai is she
complaining that he's the boss and he's
in charge or she's like oh i'm glad he
bought this bow i don't know how boats
work i just want to [ __ ] have a
cocktail i'm being misogynist cool you
work out the poor fees i don't give a
[ __ ] damn it so they love misogynist so
the only women who don't love misogynist
are the women who are too ugly to get
[ __ ] by a misogynist and then they
want to come along and try and cancel
you on the internet i don't give a [ __ ]
cancel me i will stand up right here and
say i am sexist now i don't mean that in
a bad way right because i'm sexist both
ways i try and say this all the time but
no one can seem to fathom it especially
not feminists with their minuscule
brains there are certain things in the
world that i only trust men with and
there's certain things in the world that
i only trust women with i'm not talking
about superiority because superiority is
field dependent men are better at
certain things
one thing you can never let a woman do
the top thing a woman you'd never let
her do over a minute oh there's loads of
things bro loads of things what's the
topic
i think the number one thing so
anything that is violence related women
should be nowhere near so give an
example my woman is very well trained
that if it goes off in the street
she needs to just run and scream if i
say [ __ ] off leave and i'll tell you why
i have seen the number of times i've
seen a man walking with this chick
some beef goes the girl tries to like
get in the way she doesn't want her man
or the fight to happen get him get hurt
did i i've seen a woman try to get in
the way that uh then she turns to her
own man gets hold of his arm like don't
don't holds his primary weapon when he
gets knocked the [ __ ] out and she's
holding on his [ __ ] right hand
kale headstone
stupid [ __ ] now her intentions may have
been pure
but she just [ __ ] ended her man's
life he made a video that's why he never
holds his woman's hand when he when in
public how is she gonna hold my primary
fighting hand if [ __ ] goes down i'm
screwed i don't gotta be like get off me
[ __ ]
it's hilarious
i mean he grows up in such a different
world that this makes perfect sense for
the environment that he grew up in but
he's not wrong
in any environment if if a
bad guy will call it just for simplicity
get out of here go wrong and you're like
hey no no we can work this out with this
guy like and you're and you're holding
him back from protecting himself and you
like get out of the way move [ __ ]
get out the
my way there's a big [ __ ] crack in
the facade i'd rather writing on the
wall won't last long